today the supreme court of the united
states
expressly took away a constitutional
right from the american people
that had already recognized
they didn't limit it they simply took it
away
that's never been done to a right so
important to so many americans
but they did it
it's a sad day for the court and for the
country
50 years ago roe v wade
was decided and has been the law of the
land since then
this landmark case protected a woman's
right to choose
her right to make intensely personal
decisions with her doctor
free from the entertainment from the
interference of politics
it reaffirmed basic principles of
equality
that women have the power to control
their own destiny
and it reinforced a fundamental right of
privacy
the right of each of us to choose how to
live our lives
now with rogue on
let's be very clear
the health and life of women in this
nation
are now at risk
as chairman and ranking member of the
senate judiciary committee
as vice president now as president
united states
i've studied this case carefully
i've overseen more supreme court
confirmations than anyone today
where this case was always discussed
i believe roe v wade was the correct
decision
as a matter of constitutional law and
application of the fundamental right
to privacy and liberty and matters of
family and personal autonomy
it was a decision
on a complex matter
that drew a careful balance between a
woman's right to choose
earlier in her pregnancy
and the state's ability to regulate
later in her pregnancy
a decision with broad national consensus
that most americans of faith
and backgrounds found acceptable
that have been the law of the land for
most of the lifetime
of americans today